pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
au sommaire ce soir la télé en procès la
télévision bien sûr avec comme invité
jacques baumel claude estier frédéric
pautz cher olivier toth de vote pardon
jean ferré jean françois kahn yves meyer
pierre desproges et anémone et d'autres
invités qui sont sur le plateau que je
vous présenterai au fur et à mesure dans
le courrier nous avons un record
aujourd'hui c'est la plus longue
bafouille que nous ayons reçue elle nous
vient de
d'un groupe de lycéens de province voici
donc c'est très longue bafouille et je
veux dire qu'elle est fort sympathique
pour une fois ci sont pas des insultes
et comme ils veulent venir à l'émission
nous les invitons bien sûr et les
lycéens qui veulent venir nous faire la
même chose simplement proposé nous des
sujets de débat est vite nous assure
quoi vous voulez de quoi vous voulez
parler parce qu'il faut au moins avoir
quelque chose à dire alors dans les
prochaines émissions nous avons la
semaine prochaine un sujet sur le jeu
les joueurs le tiercé les casinos ça
vous intéresse et donc un jour une
émission consacrée au féminisme est
alors voici le sujet de ce soir c'est à
dire un référendum de notre confrère
france soir et voici les sacs postaux il
ya quarante deux mille répond je crois
et bien c'est sur ce référendum de
françois que nous allons commencer notre
émission avec nos invités et je vais
tout de suite demandé à thierry
desjardins qui est directeur de la
rédaction de france soir que nous
expliquer ce petit référendum je vous
montre aussi la couverture du journal
puisque voici 92 vous allez nous citer
les chiffres tirés du jardin mais je
dois dire que le titre est assez à
extraordinaire parce qu'une bombe
atomique serait tombé sur un pays
étranger on n'aurait pas mis un titre
plus gros que sur six colonnes et oui on
est nous avons eu l'idée d'organiser ce
référendum parce que depuis des mois
nous étions submergés de courrier nos
lecteurs qui protestaient donc donné
l'idée d'organiser un peu simple soit
exactement ce que les gens reprocher
nous avons donc publié un questionnaire
le plus objectif possible qu'ils avaient
toujours trois réponses restent mieux s
moins bien et ça même chose à regarder
vous plus souvent et ils ont été surpris
par le flot de réponse que nous avons
eues puisque avril 43 mille réponses et
pour donner une comparaison bertin nous
organisons un concours avec un voyage à
gagner au bout du monde
et en faisant beaucoup de bruit autour
ce concours nous avons vingt mille
réponses à peu près et la légende est
absolument rien à gagner de au contraire
découper le questionnaire le rep ont
trouvé une enveloppe timbrée posté là
43000 réponse en cinq jours ce qui
prouve en tous les cas qui la passionne
les gens à l'intérêt de ces réponses qui
peuvent être inquiétante pour certains
c'est que les gens qui ont répondu
correspondent à peu près on peut
toujours chic années allant change le
national il ya des programmes sociaux il
ya des noms un nom olivier tàu dites
vous bien m'excuser olivier vous dites
vous même
des dizaines de milliers de réponses de
france soir à notre référendum
télévision ont été dépouillés par
ordinateur il est représentatif cet
échantillon du profil sociodémographique
des lectrices et des lecteurs de
france-soir laquelle il s'est donc pas
de la pâte la nation de même les
lecteurs du monde ne sont pas
représentatifs ils sont honorables les
éditeurs de jeux très honorable
considérable là je fais l'acteur c'est
une différence non h est d'accord avec
toi n'avait que 17 ans ceci représente
pas la france pas du tout safram envie
d'acheter vos j'en ai peut-être pas
d'accord du tout avec ce que vous pensez
de pas que vous avez publié dans france
soir mme excusez moi monsieur mais je ne
crois pas que vous représentiez toute la
fin ça je ne prétends pas représenter
toute la france si vous voulez faire un
homme est intéressant parce que il ya
des gens de en use de tous les âges de
province de paris on peut dire non et où
les violateurs de françois mais tous
longueur de soir en soir
pourtant un jour notre est spécialisé
chez que notre label notre lectorat est
assez étendue cela dit votre télévision
peut-être merveilleuse non mais thierry
thierry desjardins
une autre précision sondages oui c'est
trop facile
non vous reconnaitre il est maintenant
philippe meyer précise n'avait justement
est joliment dit c'est un référendum je
trouve que c'est
auteur de grand soir on l'a c'est moi je
voudrais ajouter n est pas du tout
laissez-moi expliquer d'abord que la
différence entre le référendum et le
sondage c'est que le sondage on va
interroger des gens on pose une question
à l'ap le référendum les gens de même
décidera la bombe et que là ce sont des
gens qui ont décidé de vous répondre et
on sait qu'en général les gens qui
écrivent dans ces cas là ce sont plutôt
les mécontents en exode accord là et là
ils sont plutôt mécontents oui mais 92,8
c'est presque les 90 à 9,8 oui mais ils
sont enchantés que l'électeur n'a rien
contre l'envoyant au long des sentiers
claude estier c'est une petite question
intéressant que vous avez combien de
lecteurs françois illy à 480 milles
personnes qui achètent tous les jours
françois bon donc il ya à peine 10 % des
vecteurs qui ont répondu très bien je
dois de série gagnante défiance de la
télévision actuelle que j'avançais
c'était un point de méthodologie vrai
que la plupart des sondeurs vous ferai
remarquer en passant est une fois de
plus les lecteurs de françois sont des
gens aussi honorable que ceux du monde
avec eux ceux des nouvelles littéraires
et que ceux de l'unité et je sais que
nombreux je précise que c'est 10% des
vecteurs de france soir vous me
permettrez de dire avant de la parole à
jacques baumel que claude estier et
rédacteur en chef de l'unité et est
naturellement député ps et que jacques
baumann qui demande la parole et député
rpr l'ancien ministre jacques baumel oui
puisqu'on parle de méthodologie et qu'on
critique les sondages et les réponses
qui sont pourtant écrasante de sourdre
est quand même en critique pas les
sondages en massage permet effet je n'ai
pas l'intention je vous interromps que
je souhaiterais une remise en cause
elle a l'esprit de l'assemblée ne nous
interromprons pas entre nous tout au
moins tous les rêves à l'assemblée je
pense que ce que vous ne démentirait pas
monsieur estiot c'est les résultats
alors extrêmement précis de fr3 qui
annonce officiellement aujourd'hui que
l'écouté passée de 27% à 24 %
alors ça c'est plus qu'un sondage par
conséquent je préfère vous permettez que
je suis dans le creux mais non elle
augmenté sur antenne 2 lancers savez
d'estivaux signale que de même une
retraite pascal fear 3 est un peu la
chaîne la plus politisée et quand n 2
est dirigée par un bon professionnel
monsieur des coupes
je ne voudrais pas faire la guerre de 14
des sondages parce que le monde ce soir
dit des sondages indiquent une relative
constance de l'audience valeur des
chaînes de télévision exactement cinéma
sombre et un mot un bobo philippe meyer
de télévision juste dire que on s'amuse
à rendre le plus confus possible la
perception qu'on peut avoir du problème
de la télévision d'une part en baptisant
sondage des choses qui ne sont pas des
sondages mais des référendum est encore
des référendum dans un sens précis c'est
de référendum auprès des lecteurs d'un
journal et plusieurs journaux qui ont
fait la même chose que françois et ça
n'est pas un référendum au sens d'une
consultation populaire et où d'autre
part comme tous ces sondages et c'est
référendum où ces enquêtes express pose
des questions extrêmement vague on en
arrive à des conclusions qui n'ont aucun
intérêt car ce que vient de dire
monsieur baumel et faire 3 a perdu 3% de
téléspectateurs faire 3 le reconnaissant
lui même on aurait du mal à mettre ça en
doute
seulement on sait que par ailleurs ces 3
% de téléspectateurs se sont
vraisemblablement puisque l'audience
d'antenne 2 est en augmentation d'autant
reporter sur un thème de quelles
conclusions peut-on en tirer pas que la
télévision est mauvaise les
programmateurs sent déjà que 3 % les
oreilles des gens qui regardaient et fr3
ont trouvé que les programmes d'antenne
2 était meilleure c'est la seule chose
qu en toute honnêteté vous puissiez dire
le reste et non pas une question de
sondage
une question d'opinion lieu de nous
chasser sur les sondages oui on essaie
de savoir tenir droit
parler les morts ni les sons et ne fait
pas parler du passé vous m'avez parlé
des téléspectateurs qui parle sans moi
tous ces sondages on oubliera les
sondages ensuite philippe cas le les
sondages vous intéresse particulièrement
puisque vous vous êtes pdg d'une agence
de publicité l'agencé fellmann cas le et
si vous travaillez sur les sondages
ça fait partie de mon métier ce que je
voudrais dire en essayant de faire
comprendre la différence entre tous ces
sondages c'est que on recense deux
choses différentes les torchons et les
serviettes
d'un côté on recense les attitudes c'est
à dire ce que les gens pensent de la
télévision ce qu'ils disent de la
télévision et de l'autre c'est l'étude
du monde
le ceo centre d'études d'opinion recense
le comportement tu es à ce qu'ils font
et c'est là que c'est intéressant parce
qu'au niveau de l'attitude
je soupçonne les français de dire je
suis contre la télé parce qu'ils ont
l'air intelligent
quelle qu'elle soit et celle d'avant mai
et celle d'aujourd'hui
ce qui est important c'est effectivement
de voir qu'en termes de comportement il
ya un léger recul c'est vrai globalement
on peut dire qu'il ya environ 1 %
probablement de désaffection par rapport
à l'ensemble des chaînes et des
variations à l'intérieur l'une de
l'autre mais on peut pas dire que les
français ont abandonné la télévision et
c'est en cela que je dis que le grand
site de france soir pourrait laisser
percevoir des choses qui n'existent pas
parce que l'on sent abandonnée michel
gérard longuet vous êtes vous fait juste
un sentiment de frustration parce que
les indices d'écouté ne sont plus
publiés et ils ont le sentiment qu'on
tient pas compte de leur avis alors
quand ils ont la possibilité de
s'exprimer
ils expriment un avis négatif mais si on
tenait compte de leur avis plus souvent
je crois qu'il y aurait un apaisement
dans les relations entre le
téléspectateur et la télé via ce que
vous lisez une question là dessus a dit
oui est ce qu'on peut savoir quelle
comédienne monsieur longuet ou monsieur
baumel ou d'autres personnes ici tir en
ce qui concerne les programmes de ce qui
a été dit c'est à dire est ce que
monsieur longuet qui par exemple a été
pendant un certain temps quand il était
encore député administrateur d'edf peut
nous dire s'il était encore aujourd'hui
administrateur d'une société de
programmes qu est ce qu il ferait quel
programme il supprimerait et par quoi
ils les remplaceraient ou et cela va
continuer
j'aimerais pas rendu à ce domaine sur la
télévision a brillé en 10 secondes
premièrement rétablir le contact avec le
téléspectateur et publiés les indices
des couillons que le sait les
spectateurs aient le sentiment d'être
pris en considération votre foin
deuxième manche était ce deuxième borne
sont tous faire éclater le goulot
d'étranglement des trois chênes nous
avons des possibilités techniques
formidable on peut avoir quatre cinq six
sept chaînes
il faut donner aux téléspectateurs la
visite est de choisir il a le sentiment
d'aller à une réserve gémissements
derrière je pense moi liviana du pas de
malentendu je pense qu'il ne fait mieux
qu'il ya un malaise autour la télévision
en ce moment et il n'est pas seulement à
droite dans l'ex majorité il était mieux
dans les électeurs la majorité actuelle
et il ya eu un sondage récemment où on
disait que 68 % des téléspectateurs et
n'étaient pas satisfaits le chiffre
importe peu mais à un moment donné on
leur demandait si vous aviez à décider
de la programmation
que feriez vous ça a l'air très bien
très cintrée démocratique l'auront 10 et
25% informations 25% dry étaient les
enfants et ce qu'on disait on disait de
3% jeudi que ça c'est scandaleux que des
directeurs de chaînes doivent tenir
compte
c'est ça et c'est le mot juste derrière
compte mais c'est le général de gaulle a
je crois qu on ait un gouvernement non
plus exclusivement avec des sondes
denise bombardier a demandé la parole
depuis un bon moment denise bombardier
journaliste journaliste à radio canada
l'avait oublié quelques années un livre
soit télévision française qui avait été
un peu une bombe car elle l'était à ces
critiques
et oui et c'était assez critique
prévisions françaises façade de la
télévision il ya quelques années y ait
de quelle année fait 5,75 bon donc vous
pouvez faire la comparaison un mot de
nice pour moi si vous permettez c'est
parce que moi je vois ça l'extérieur là
vous êtes en train de vous disputer sur
les sondages est une chose qu'il faut
dire parce que il faut pas faire dire
autre chose ce qu'elles ne sont pas
selon qu'on est de gauche ou de droite
dans tous les pays occidentaux à l'heure
actuelle il ya une désaffection pour la
télévision qui ne se manifestent pas par
des baisses de cotes d'écouté de 4 5%
mais qui commence à se manifester par
des baisses de cotes d écoute de
un ennemi 2% cinéma partout et ça c'est
un phénomène occidental donc si vous
partez de ça pour évaluer ce qu'ils
voient de télévision selon que vous
l'aimez ou que vous lui aimé parce que
vous êtes d'accord politiquement vous
n'êtes pas d'accord politiquement avec
qui gouverne la france vous allez faire
fausse route et c'est une fausse
discussion on est ici pour discuter du
contenu de la télévision on la regarde
vous l'avez vous la regardez je les
regardais moi aussi récemment durant
quelques semaines je pense qu'on est ici
pour ça bien ici autrement on va se
perdre et ça ne veut rien dire parce que
dans mon pays aussi la cote des coupes
baisse il n'y a pas eu de prise du
pouvoir par les socialistes aux moines
mais oui un petit grain un petit grain
de pays ou de pierre desproges un grand
louis avant celle ci voulait non est-ce
qu'il faut pas perdre de vue c'est que
ce que les gens reprochent à la
télévision en ce moment c'est d'être
ennuyeuse c'est pas des socialistes
c'est la amélien de taille cela non je
crois pas alors je vous donne encore un
dernier un dernier sondage parce qu'on
va terminer que ces sondages 'journal du
dimanche' demain publie un sondage qui
prouverait que là encore 76% des
français trouvent que la division
actuelle est de mauvaise qualité
66 % seraient en faveur d'une télévision
privée voilà le premier sondage qui tous
à ce sujet ou 68% pour une quatrième
chaîne privée mais je signale qu'il ya
une fin pas radox curieux 48 % craignent
qu'en cas de chaînes privées il y ait
une mainmise de des puissances d'argent
et un abandon du service public c'est
sûr contre contre une minorité de 42 %
ce qui est paradoxal il souhaite la
chaîne privée ils craignent les
conséquences
dernière question posée paradoxalement
celle des paradoxes intello dsi et wii
si vous permettez je voudrais revenir
sur un mot que monsieur longuet a dû
tout à leur reprendre contact avec le
téléspectateur
eh bien je dis que là on lance le débat
sur une idée complètement fausse
il n'y a pas intérêt spectateurs il n'y
a pas un téléspectateur moyen qui serait
non mais non il y a des téléspectateurs
qui ont des goûts aussi différents que
l'ensemble des français peuvent avoir
des goûts différents
et si vous cherchez à faire une
télévision pour un téléspectateur moyen
qui n'existe pas bien vous n'aurez
jamais la réponse et vous n'aurez jamais
cette innovation
je voudrais simplement pour suis
vraiment
l'idée sera seul point pour interroger
monsieur thierry desjardins par ce que
j'ai lu avec beaucoup d'attention ce
qu'écrit france-soir aujourd'hui et je
le dis sous sa plume
nous voulons des soirées qui nous
plaisent à nous les modestes
téléspectateurs les simples clients très
bien et puis je tourne la page et je
vois au taux de france soir toujours
l'étude des résultats montrent qu'il n'y
a pas une émission qui fasse l'unanimité
le choix des téléspectateurs est très
dispersé
et bien voilà donc un formidable
contradictions en attendant
l'explication de votre propre sondage
sont dûment baiadera chez nous voulons
et puis il dit ensuite que les
téléspectateurs ou des choix divers
problèmes permanents de point que les
télévisions sous n'importe quel
gouvernement bommel et essayer de
satisfaire un public extrêmement rare y
est nous avons sur le les commentaires
de françois sont un petit peu
bizarroïdes par moments quand on met le
palmarès des des vedettes gicquel cavada
bellemare c'est drôle que ce soit
expliqué d'ailleurs ils étaient partis
depuis longtemps me reste un des taxes
l'allemagne a donné il ya un commentaire
qui dit ce ne sont pas des intellectuels
ceux qui sont dont 1 et se met
facilement à la portée du public
moi j'aime pas le relent légèrement
poujadiste des commentaires pourcentage
je vous dis pas que votre opinion même
pas le côté à lady jane cia la rive
gauche non plus oui mais alors comment
je le dirais également quelque chose
c'est que je serai d'éric lecerf
je ne comprends pas et j'admets très
difficilement que les journalistes ou
qui se disent tel de la télévision fasse
tant de battage qui ont leur propre nom
je trouve ça scandaleux
absolument moi j'ai passé 22 ans la
télévision monsieur baumel et à la radio
je suis un ancien combattant qui vous
permettait j'espère ne pas en avoir leur
lit
j'espère ne pas en le site mais je veux
dire ceci c'est que vraiment moi j'étais
bien à la portant dans des conditions
incroyables
j'ai été plastiquée on m'a promis un
ministre m'a écrit pour me dire vous
allez recevoir un chèque de dix mille
francs gelé pas encore reçu
ce sont les faits étaient faux alors je
voudrais dire tout de même merci merci
frédéric pautz cher j'en ferai une
attente jean ferré à écouter frédéric
auxerre présente à des grands exclus de
la division de 68 et claude darget parce
que j'ai le droit de parler sinon le
droit de réponse et on a beaucoup moins
parlé non des solutions de claude darget
délit mais aussi leurs yeux de votre
trempe de série mercy en outre que je
lui donne la parole janvier j'ai écrit
tifouti ckoi yotine vous verrez des
critiques en ferry mais je peux m'ont
expliqué si vous le voulez j'ai dormi
c'est à l'occasion il est critique de
télévision au figaro magazine
s'intéressait la parole il ya 20 minutes
que nous sommes là et depuis 20 minutes
nous ne parlons que sondages
les téléspectateurs la raison je crois
que c'est le tiers de l'émission qui
vient de s'écouler voilà pourquoi je ne
suis pas intervenu avant et voilà
pourquoi excusez moi je vous interrompue
parce que pour intéressant que soit
votre passé et je le reste mais je
n'allais ans qu'il est très intéressant
n'est pas le sujet de ce sont
aujourd'hui il est très intéressant ce
n'est pas que ça ne sera jamais le sujet
qui je le suis par monsieur il me
permettait j'ai le droit de dire ce que
j'ai en cause le droit aux six mois nous
avons tous le droit
on va laisser la parole à sélestat
parents l'avaient déclarée qui est dans
le magazine qui a le droit de parler
comme c'est bien sûr mais redevient mais
je je vous remercie
nous étions entrain disputer pour savoir
si le sondage était quelques pourcent
près vrai ou faux 92 % de mécontents
qu'il y en ait 5% ou 10% de plus ou de
moins ça ne change rien ça n'est pas un
problème quantitatif c'est un problème
qualitatif
les français en ont marre de la
télévision 44 43 mille lecteurs de
france martèle que ce soit 80 je réponds
à jean ferrat n'a pas pu parler laisser
la parole à jean ferré aller alors je
crois que ce qui serait intéressant ce
serait d'aller au fond du problème est
d'éliminer tous ses à côtés et je
voudrais dire quelque chose qui va peut
être choquer les lecteurs du figaro
magazine c'est que je ne suis dans cette
affaire d'accord ni avec la majorité ni
avec l'opposition
je suis convaincu que les français en
ont marre de la télévision pourquoi mais
je ne suis pas tellement convaincu
qu'elle soit beaucoup plus mauvaise
qu'avant mais non ce dont je suis sûr
c'est que les français en ont marre
alors pourquoi les français ont-ils marc
avec une télévision qui n'est pas
tellement pire si vous le volet on peut
étudier en quoi il est pire et en quoi
l'état changé eh bien les français en
ont marre parce que le climat a changé
parce que les français ont enlevé leurs
lunettes roses
parce que le climat est mauvais et parce
que l'air est d'une certaine façon pour
alors j'ai réfléchi à la question parce
que je reçois beaucoup de courrier au
figaro magazine sur ce sujet et je me
suis aperçu d'une chose est bien c'est
que tout à coup les français se trouve
devant un pouvoir vieux savez vous
quelle est l âge moyen des trois
personnes qui dirigeait la france
lorsque giscard a pris le pouvoir c'est
à dire le président de la république le
premier ministre et demie d'audience
étaient 46 ans
maintenant ses 68 ans et à la télé par
rapport au neuf roses ans mais est ce
que monsieur peu de chair vient de dire
tout à l'heure c'est qu'il y a un esprit
de revanche c'est que des gens qui
reviennent veulent parler de leur combat
passé ça peut être très intéressant mais
de cela je crois que les français omar
il se trouve tout à coup de vent un
pouvoir vieux avec des gens vieux bon
alors on peut à l'heure suite la
transition de réponse pour les jeunes y
sont bons le rajeunissement vous parliez
tout à l'heure que les niveaux des
dettes à l'heure de la télévision privée
bon alors ça prend même très compliqué
il ya du pour et du contre et je
voudrais vous signaler que c'est ce
jeune homme de giscard qui n'a jamais
jamais voulu c'est le rpr et c'est lui
ds qui n'a jamais voulu de télévision
privée et qu'en france c'est pas la
peine pour le moment de parler de
télévision privée car nous savons que
tous les grands partis ils sont hostiles
alors on peut en parler pendant des
heures ça ne fera pas avancer le
problème du tout s'il y avait un
véritable référendum national pas dans
france soir dans les urnes ça serait
peut-être différent on peut parler de
télévision privée dans les réserves au
nom du libéralisme qui vous est ce pire
est monsieur baumel m'inspire toujours
vous auriez dû être plus longs la
télévision a laissé tellement les freins
si demain la télévision pour l'elysée
enfin qu'ils veulent une télévision +
indépendance plus libre du pouvoir
semble t il
et c'est la raison pour laquelle cet
examen la promène son agent une
télévision qui soit à l'abri de toutes
les tentations et ils craignent d'autres
tensions
c'est à dire que la télévision aux
cousins qui aujourd'hui est présenté aux
français que vous le vouliez ou non
apparaît comme véritablement trop
orienté trop politisé et c'est le
champion du monde
faut ce n'est pas ce qui est dit dieu
souhaité plus près je m'excuse regardez
revenir au temps du tout engagé
70% des français trop engagé objective
1%
bon allez trop engagé il a il a fallu le
l'événement du mois noël pour que nous
ayons enfin une émission honnête sur
l'accord qui n'a pas encore parlé
la pression américaine d'après ce que je
sais l'humanité a fait un sondage auprès
des électeurs qui considère que la
télévision est très anti communiste
c'est très intéressant ce que j'ai dit
ce que je vous dis qu'à nice couleur
verte h2ktv
on va revenir aux comptes on l'a vu que
j'ai pas année dans 10 ou 50 ce qu'il
dira pas de cette émission mais la
télévision française
c'est que son mollet sougy sous le
général de gaulle sous pompidou à
quelques mois près sous giscard et je le
regrette mais probablement aussi sous
mitterrand en ce moment si le coup de
barre n'est pas donné la télévision fait
partie d'un système des dépouilles
inavoués tous les pouvoirs veulent
garder la main dessus c'est triste mais
les étrangers le pense enfin à venise
l'année bombardier ou y faire sauter le
monop a dit denise bombardier alors
maintenant on attend des choses danis
bombardier à la télévision ce que les
gens n'aiment pas et aussi dans les
autres télévisions des autres pays
c'est l'agressivité verbale à la
télévision quand on parle tous ensemble
le téléspectateur sa réaction c'est de
rejeter tout ce qu'on dit et j'aime
beaucoup vous entendre parler français
parce que je vous trouve très
intéressant très vivant et très drôle
quand vous parlez mais si vous parlez
tous ensemble les téléspectateurs n'aime
pas ça et je crois que d'un dandy ray
dans des résultats son âge c'est ça
qu'ils expriment au fond c'est parce que
vous dites c'est la façon dont vous le
dites bon une chose premièrement
deuxièmement si on parlait du contenu de
la télévision
qu'est ce que vous faites vous vous
répondrais rapidement que finalement ils
disent qu'ils n'aiment pas ça mais les
sondages auprès le contraire et que je
peux vous dire entre parenthèses que
cette émission malheureusement ont
malgré tout ce que l'on dit atteint 14 %
d'audience en moyenne le seul mois de
janvier contre 11 % des 100 alors qu'une
petite émission à deux personnages comme
l'émission faisait monsieur elkabbach
autrefois car tu clames n'avait que 4 %
d'audience
[Rires]
12 je ferrais voyez vous avez raison on
l'espère revanche danis bombardier
regarder denise bombardier oui je ne
voulais pas je disais simplement comment
tout le monde parle ensemble
malheureusement les gens sont associés
jeu se disent mon dieu qui les laisse
dont parlait on va les écouter un après
l'autre puisque ici tout le monde a
droit de parole et ce qui était
peut-être un peu nouveau dans cette
télévision lorsque j'ai écrit ce livre
en 1975 j'avais j'avais écrit
malheureusement je regrette d'avoir eu
raison à ce jour n'est ce pas monsieur
estier j'avais écrit si jamais la gauche
pointe toujours à cause de la de la
culture de ce pays à cause des pratiques
démocratiques dans ce pays j'ai peur que
ce soit la même chose
or ce qu'il faut bien constater depuis
le mois de mai ça fait quand même un
certain un certain temps maintenant
quelques mois c'est que c'est un peu la
même chose vous savez quand j'ai vu ça
commençait très rapidement les
déclarations de votre ministre fini ou
du ministre responsable de la télévision
monsieur la même hall comment fabriquer
alors quand j'ai vu ses déclarations sur
la télévision quand j'ai vu certaines
déclarations de monsieur est-il sur la
télévision
quand je vois le pdg de la télévision
venir dire dans une émission remarquable
fait par un fait part de ses
réalisateurs de talent que lol que le
reportage sélectif est une atteinte à
mon tour les journalistes qu'ils soient
là tant désirée pour désigner tel vous
faites allusion
mais tu l'aimés un film qui a été tourné
il ya deux ans et qui avait été
interdite par giscard sur le mec il a
été c'est du temps du temps
alors dites moi une chose denise
bombardier barrabourg au canada par
exemple vous trouvez que au canada par
exemple il ya moins d'interférence entre
le politique et notre vision écoutez je
suis pas ici pour donner deux là sont
d'autant plus que cette volonté est un
pays que j'aime mais pour toutes les
raisons du mans la première parce que
mes ancêtres y était mais il est certain
d'une chose
moi je fais une émission politique je
suis l'interviewer politique jamais un
ministre ne va m'appeler ce n'est pas
dans les moeurs chez nous et si par
hasard il appelle un de mes patrons ce
que je ne doute jamais on veut comique
issa ce qui fait que ça c'est tout un
autre climat qui permet de travailler
avec beaucoup plus d'aisance et si la
télévision à l'heure actuelle elle est
tellement en question ici les gens ont
tellement de difficultés à faire des
émissions et si effectivement je pense
que les les français ne sont pas
satisfaits c'est parce que les gens ne
peuvent pas travailler dans un clip dans
un climat de liberté et la télévision
vous savez c'est le tendon d'achille de
la démocratie moi je peux vous dire
denis de mon parti que depuis que j'ai
fait cette émission jeunesse personnes
bien mais je ne parle pas encore de vous
mais je regarde les ministres par les
hommes politiques qui se mêlent parce
que les ombres et vous savez dans ce
pays on respecte le temps la hiérarchie
quant au ministre parle ça a plus de
poids et plus d'impact par exemple dans
mon pays parce que les rapports
hiérarchiques sont infiniment moins doux
alors il est évident qu'à ce moment là
quand un ministre par les journalistes
sont en chantant sont en stand-by et ne
peuvent pas ne pas penser que ça peut un
jour est visé alors je dis que c'est au
fond c'est toute notre société qui est à
changer et est la preuve la télévision à
l'heure actuelle et fait la preuve que
profondément ce pays n'a pas encore
changé même si économiquement il ya des
choses très importantes que les adieux
le dire n'a en conclusion parce que vous
avez écrit en 75 livres sur la
télévision française
il vous l'a jugé très mauvaise non mais
c'est intéressant que d'avoir cette
précision parce que quand monsieur
baumel part de notre télévision
j'ai enterré alors sur ce point nous
allons avant la vidéo alors j'en ferai
ensuite jean françois granet l'esprit
qui est le mot climat
quand je vous disais que je pensais que
la télévision n'avait pas beaucoup
changé c'est parce que si vous relevez
puisque nous faisions des statistiques
relever les programmes et vous verrez
qu'il ya très peu de nouveaux qui sont
en général plutôt mauvais que bon mais
il ya très peu de changements mais il y
a le climat du journal il ya des gens
qui font une gueule comme ça qui tous
vous disent la même chose
à la même heure vous passez d'une chaîne
sur l'aude c'est la même chose et c'est
ce climat qui perturbe tout je crois que
ce serait intéressant que nous parlions
du climat et du pourquoi de la chose à
soi disant françois également des
professionnels par quelques jours
nouveau centre c'est toute la sphère toi
non oui je crois qu'il faut mélanger
il faut pas mélanger de problème n'est
ce pas de l'information et les
programmes on peut quoi qu'on dise sur
les sondages c'est vrai il faut pas le
nier qu'il ya actuellement un phénomène
de malaise un phénomène de rejet des
nouveaux programmes à tort ou à raison
pour en parler milliards pour la peine
de chipoter ce qui concerne la formation
différente pendant deux mois de
formation il trouve que j'ai participé à
cette information de la télévision
d'avant l'e-mail j'y étais j'ai pu
constater personne ne peut nier que le
système était pervers monsieur baumel
n'est ce pas je veux dire aujourd'hui
une personne ne nie plus il était
malsain il était pervers précis je vous
dirais qu'il est encore aujourd'hui je
vous dirais qu'il est encore jeune homme
il était parce que tout simplement c'est
une télévision d'état dont le patron est
l'état et cala francs en france on
mélange l'état et la majorité et on
mélange la majorité et le parti dominant
donc en vérité c'est la télévision du
marquis nominaux du parti dominant
attendez je vais vous investirez
attendait brut que son serait très bonne
si vous ne posiez après quand je vais
peut-être vous répondre vous savez moi
je ne suis pas aussi partisan militant
et dogmatique après ce que je viens en
partant je suis allé voir que je vais
vous donner après ce que je viens de
tenir
je vais vous étonner derrière ma
modération et au contraire insisté j'ai
donc je vous pouvez me reprochez vous
auriez raison d'avoir servi à que
d'alibi d'ailleurs c'est vrai je faisais
le jeu quand j'ai pu parler quand j'ai
fait une chronique je les fais
d'ailleurs tout à fait librement je veux
dire par là que ce que j'ai envie de
dire je disais disons que quand je lui
redis chronique que je proposais on
accepter une une sur dix c'est déjà pas
mal
c'est passé mais c'est déjà pas mal
alors il va de rester de trois mois sans
rien faire mais ça au fond c'est agraire
et cette télévision d'ailleurs il faut
dire est une chose monsieur estier c'est
que cette source une télévision de
monsieur longuet qui essayait de faire
en sorte qu'on ne parle pas des amis de
monsieur baumel il faut dire la vérité
car cette télévision était dirigée avant
tout est alors à un point incroyable
contre monsieur chirac le rpr
c'était on eu un monsieur baumel
reconnaissez vous n'y verrez qu'on
connaît dans un étier pas content s'il y
avait des visions qui se vouent
censurait qui censurait les propos des
gaullistes qui censurait tout ce que
faisait mention bien qu'ils biologiques
comme madame mais laissez-moi le penser
à ce qu'on est sur le présent comme si
moi jean françois kahn terminé lundi
après vient d être bien les élections
j'ai eu une très grande surprise c'est
que allant à la télévision entre les
deux tours ayant été choqués par un
certain nombre de choses qui s'était
passé entre les deux tours jean - été
exprimées j'avais vu une rédaction
finalement assez mal mais cette
rédaction après le 10 mai ouhlala alors
là elle était plus mal du tout bekhti
vivement une grande agitation comme
j'aurais aimé qu'ils lui avant car il y
avait de quoi avant pourquoi après c'est
vrai qu'il est choquant de voir des
journalistes à voir s'il y eu la mort
revendique après le 10 mai ce qu'on eût
aimé qu'ils revendiquent as tous quelle
que soit leur opinion au nom de la
liberté avant le 10 mai à ce moment là
il ya eu des réunions et on a dit il
faut changer il faut mettre à la porte
un tel changement c'est le changement
dame et j'ai défendu la position que
puisque le système est pervers il est
pervers de toute façon et que donc il ne
fallait rien changé car si on changeait
or entraînant système de l'ancien
de l'eau de l'ancienne télévision ça
veut dire qu'on remplace un homme du
pouvoir par un autre homme du pouvoir
le monsieur nommé par le ministre paraît
monsieur nommé par le ministre il
fallait donc en rien changé rires
jusqu'au moment et surtout pas comme on
l'a fait car la façon dont s'est fait
quelques matches qu'on a été misérable
mais en plus il fallait attendre
enfin ce statut que personne ne nous a
donné jusqu'à présent qui ferait de la
télévision une télévision indépendante
du pouvoir totalement libre de pouvoir
etc alors on changerait tout ce qu'on
veut car personne n'est propriétaire de
son émission de son journal faut quand
même le dire sur ces pages chaud quand
quelqu'un vous dit c'est tendu démission
cette personne qui nous a fait pleurer
parce qu'on vous dise est en délire on
disait 1
on n'est pas propriétaire et des gens
qui aimeraient faire de télévision en
france vient donc on changeait pas
choquant mais qu'on change dans le cadre
d'un système qui donne l indépendance
liberté
j'ai scellé c'est la position que j'ai
défendu on ne m'a pas écouté comme vous
savez j'ai démissionné
je vous signale que je suis seul je suis
fan des missionnaires de la télévision
après le 10 mai entre parenthèses et
j'ai décidé de me reconvertir dans la
chansonnette
si je pouvais rien ne va pas beaucoup
apprécié ouais entre nous on sait d'où
les gens entre nous si tous les gens qui
ne faisaient plus de politique à la
télévision ou de leur fait ou pas de
leur fait se reconvertissent est dans la
chansonnette on rigolerait dr il ya
encore au sucre 1 mort et enterré mais
c'est que vraiment je n'ai jamais
reproché que vous soyez la télévision
sous l'ancien régime ce que je reproche
c'est que dans nouveau régime
il n'y ait plus un jean françois kahn de
l'autre côté qui est des chroniques non
merci j'ai enterré attendez je voudrais
donner un petit peu la parole aux
téléspectateurs parce que nous en avons
quelques uns qui ont fait venir il en
reste encore vous voulez prendre le
micro
voilà vous appeler monsieur luc et vous
est le seul angle je suis coursier voilà
landreau d'occasionnels 1
téléspectateurs 98 % mais non non non
j'ai pas du tout écrit aoûtiens journal
moi c'est pas mon problème je m'arrête
seulement aux films et aux sports
sorti de là je regarde pas la télévision
parce qu'elle ne m'intéresse pas voilà
vous avez quand même dans les nouveaux
programmes j'ai eu plaisir de voir eddy
mitchell le présenter une nouvelle
chronique là sur le cinéma ration c'est
pas mal dommage que ce soit une fois par
mois ce serait deux ou trois fois par
mois ce serait pas mal donc pour vous il
n'ya pas un changement particulier dans
d'aujourd'hui par rapport à l'année
sinon je me sens pas je ne sens pas la
politique n'étant les choix garde qu'un
film à l'observer dans le militaire n'y
a pas tellement de qualités claude
estier oui j'apprécie beaucoup ce que
vous venez de dire parce que l'un des
leitmotiv que l'on entend tout le temps
c'est qu'il ya plusieurs films à la
télévision
il ya actuellement tu premiers lacets
janvier du 1er janvier au 15 février
il ya eu 46 films 8 par semaine 8 par le
soir à 20h30 8,8 par semaine donc vous
avez satisfaction si vous voulez si vous
aimez skis parfaitement votre droit les
films à la télévision jusqu'à 117 kg est
parce qu il avait cependant je sais les
reproches ton plus nuancé que ça
beaucoup de gens dont on dit qu'ils sont
modestes et par là on entend
généralement qui se lève très tôt le
matin reproche à la télévision me
semble-t-il d'avoir des programmes et
les films d avoir poussé très tard je
parle de 46 films à 20h36 fléau et on a
quand même poussé du film un peu tard et
on a obligé les gens à par exemple
écouter droit de réponse
avant dallas est un exemple parmi des
hauts salaires qu'on donne une mission
du didactisme
il était extraordinairement difficile
avec moi je me souviens d'une soirée sur
antenne 2 on a d'abord eu une
introduction à la peinture mot témoin je
croyais émission ce n'est pas une
c'était une introduction il ya eu pire
que c'était plein de bonnes intentions
ce que sont aujourd'hui suivies de près
par c'était une étude une étude
peut-être mon barda telle responsabilité
partagée il s'agissait d'une étude est
allé l'argent le cerveau même si mon
fils avait longé les quais hauts
échelons dépenses là je vous en prie
parce que là c'est obligé de vous dire
le contraire parce que je crois que
vraiment mais ici on peut dire une chose
précis c'est que le gouvernement
intérieur a laissé en partant les
caisses pleines pinces et non ça
surement me dit j'ai parlé à une
réalisatrice a pas cette semaine j'ai
parlé une trentaine de personnes qui
travaillent la télévision fait ses
devoirs et cette réalisatrice m'a dit
autrefois pour tel sujet nous avions
droit à huit jours de salaire maintenant
dit coco tu auras deux jours le casque
pâti pendant que çà et là nous y allons
réunir mulard dans les caisses
je serais très heureux de savoir de la
part du gouvernement
combien ont coûté en centaines de
millions toutes les mesures de
bouleversement de la télé depuis neuf
mois et combien coûte à la télé le
doublement d'un certain nombre de postes
car actuellement dans les couloirs et
dans les bureaux je m'excuse de le dire
chez les chiffres précis il ya deux fois
plus de personnes qu'avant non pas deux
il ya deux cent cinquante et un
journalise les téléspectateurs de moins
à tanger de la non attendez une seconde
connais très bien tueur voudrais parler
ou bien que d'autres émissions écoutez
je n'ai pas les chiffres les ai demandé
on arrive à l'aja si dans l'admiration
des données comme on est cher non non
monsieur longuet non monsieur longuet le
figaro annonce et 75 millions minutes
annoncé 150 millions c'est apps de la
joie aux agressions parce qu'elles font
exactement le prix courant de tous et de
l'émission de débat elle doit tourner
autour de 30 millions 40 millions
c'est-à-dire le prix de toutes les
émissions du même genre il n'y a pas eu
un sou de plus
n'accepte aucun qui a coûté trop cher
pour cela monsieur manessier attendant
la table de moche que vous l'ayez pas
dix mois mais on est content on me l'a
pas demandé d'engagements pris que je me
tais monsieur manessi est arrivé
spécialement de perpignan alors laissez
lui la parole il est ingénieur chez
pirelli junior se nourrit ma carrière
car à dreux et s'occupe d'une
association de téléspectateurs
effectivement et étant le seul de
province ici au milieu de 25 août rené
durand sans moi je viens de la meuse
profond vous avez des activités
parisiennes autant que je me suis
d'abord étonné de voir les personnes qui
ont eu le pouvoir pendant 25 ans qui se
sont servis de la télé pour essayer de
prolonger leur province et qui essaie de
s'en servir à nouveau maintenant aux
bénéfices bien sûr de quelques jouets ou
novateur pour essayer de le retrouver
bon ça ça nous choque parce
qu'effectivement nous voudrions que la
télévision soit un petit peu
indépendante du pouvoir
nous voudrions nous aussi en province
arrivé une meilleure régionalisation
parce que sur ce plan là il faut bien
dire il ya des efforts à faire
considérable et les quelques 50 et
entreprises n'ont pas toujours été
heureux imaginez la réaction des
parisiens si pendant 20 minutes
d'émission de fr 3 ile-de-france il
devait entendre une émission en alsacien
et de c'est ce que nous subissons
quelquefois à perpignan où pendant un
quart d'heure des missions régionales
nous subissons la télévision toulouse
qui fait une émission à l'occitan que
personne de contrat en terminant parce
qu'on ne parle pas occitan à perpignan
et sète et fantaisie batelli vie mais
monsieur manessier vous même en tant que
téléspectateur que pensez vous de cette
nouvelle télévision et vous de 92,8
absolument pas j'aurais beaucoup de
choses à dire sur ces sondages
personnellement d'ailleurs ils sont
forcément très subjectif d'autant plus
que la télévision et au domaine
passionnel faut bien le dire assez ou
les réactions sont très épidermique ou
ceux qui sont contre nous exprime plus
volontiers parce qu'on a parlé de 10% et
d'acteurs de france soir c'est vrai mais
parmi ces 10 %
il y en avait forcément qu'ils étaient
des milieux qui était forcément des
névroses et il y en avait forcément je
crois qu'il y aurait beaucoup à dire
aussi
le seco avait cédé majorité de prendre
des positions politiques vous en prenez
aussi ma fille oui ça jusqu'à jouer pas
de nom mais la différence entre les
mains d'un délicieux
il se développe des programmes
précisément en disant ce programme là
même plus ce programme là ne m'a pas plu
il explique pourquoi mais je pense que
c'est ça qui est intéressant est que
c'est ça te faire avancer le changement
de la télévision dans le sens de la
qualité on voudrait qu'ils étaient les
airs et d'ailleurs et pas les grandes
malédiction que vous versez bien entendu
sans aucune arrière pensée at on à
tombeau ouvert sur la télévision ont
concerné plus de 10 millions à l'écouté
monsieur prend l'initiative tout le
monde sait ce que je suis et j'ai sur
mon front une étiquette
quand il ya un certain nombre de
nouveaux responsables de la télé
notamment à fr3 qui la voix de son
maître
personne ne dit les trois quarts sont
des socialistes je voulais suivre et des
secrétaires d'état la formation mais
comme vous étiez secrétaire d'état nous
n'avions ni c'est monsieur aulas ne
ternisse une réponse est ce la réponse
que le jeu de g ah bien sûr de fr3
perpignan était président du comité tout
en dix cars distinct je réponds que je
vous réponds je crois à bras était du
seul gouvernement
c'est à dire du gouvernement de chaban
delmas qui a tenté non sans mal est dans
l'opposition et dans la majorité de
l'époque de faire la seule réforme de
libéralisation de l'eau et rtf de
l'époque et je m'excuse de vous dire les
grenades
nous avons mis en grâce à cette époque
vous savez qui a longtemps monsieur
revient à des graisses et vous avez
revient
dernier vous avez fait des efforts vous
n'êtes pas arrivée jusqu'à la fin si on
pouvait oui par an 16 limites sur ce
point oui vous êtes est particulièrement
concerné olivier stade à cet hiver j'ai
démissionné parce que chalon était un
peu été revue dans les programmes mais
c'est pas le premier voulait désolé de
vous vendre les dédramatiser dites vous
la situation je crois que j'ai fait faut
pas exagérer après tout la télévision
c'est pas la bombe atomique qui vient de
tomber mais mais en même temps françois
digard mairie en même temps cet après
midi cet après midi même dans mon
quartier le rpr c'est bien des gens de
chez vous je crois ensuite les
distribuer des tracts de ce genre je
suis frais noter une espèce de larmes de
colère ce qui empêche de parler
calmement des problèmes et on voudrait
bien y arriver alors je me suis rarement
de pareilles méthodes et que disiez-vous
allègement la parenthèse est terminée
sur le plan politique pure je voudrais
compter avec les téléspectateurs
monsieur vauzelle
oui me dire une dernière chose
effectivement c'est que les
téléspectateurs n'apparaissent pas
beaucoup dans les futures structures de
l'audiovisuel dans le rapport moloch en
est la quintessence paraît-il que ce
soit dans la haute autorité que ce soit
dans le conseil national audiovisuel que
ce toit d'une commission régionale de
communication il n'y a aucune place pour
les téléspectateurs
alors les journaux consacrent des pages
entières et des titres le 15 cm au soi
disant aveux des téléspectateurs on les
intègre pas dans les structures alors
intéressant et les médias qui rouspètent
temps refus est inséré nos voeux une
émotion quand on leur en voilà pourquoi
il faut essayer de faire des
regroupements de téléspectateurs pour
qu'ils aient leur mot à dire dans la
discussion du prochain statut de
l'audiovisuel
c'est à dire au journal russe n'ont pas
aimé qu'il vienne l'adhésion des
français disaient la redevance qui la
paix pour pouvoir avoir une pomme
télévision mais monsieur baumel pour
l'instant non mais quel argent
laissez-moi unis s'efforcent s'il vous
plaît en tout temps le droit de juger la
télévision que vous développez l'abri
d'un riche jeune homme qui travaille aux
ptt à droite donné aussi son avis raja
les visions pense que les gens les des
hommes politiques de droite ont montré
leur incapacité en matière de télévision
et on ne veut rien d'autre robinho
jc quand les lecteurs de france soir
sont mécontents à 92% de la télévision
ce qu'ils réclament en premier ce sont
des films des films et des variétés
jamais une demande des créations jamais
des dramatiques et on dit ils ont peur
des émissions culturelles ils ne veulent
pas regarder les émissions culturelles
qu'est ce que c'est nous dénonçons
beaucoup de films autres comment on
avait donné beaucoup de films dit au
revoir qui ont été supprimés on avait
les dossiers de l'histoire ce qu'on a
supprimé 2,6 en écran voulait parler
assurant des missions qui avait été
donné que les dossiers de l'écran existe
toujours une fois par mois au louis bons
gâteaux et les tonga ions c'est la
période ici laissez-moi peut finir le
tour d'horizon rapide des
téléspectateurs sur vous elle que pensez
vous de cette nouvelle télévision est ce
que vous êtes cas parce que je pense que
ce n'est pas si mal
laissez le parler mais laissez moi
parler je faisais ça m'étonne pas que
vous la trouviez très mauvaise dans le
nez on avait plus en mai le gaz est pas
que monsieur baumel dit moir ou ce que
vous pensez moi je trouve que les
programmes sont quand même le meilleur
il ya quand même de très très bonne
émission il ya des mauvaises émission ce
qu'on a peut-être pas assez fait ces
axes et une politique culturelle et une
police sur la création sur les
dramatiques parce que les films c'est
bien mais il y en avait 54 l'année
dernière en six semaines il y en a
encore 54 ans six semaines cette année
donc quand les gens se plaignent qu'il
n'y a pas assez de films
il y en a assez de films bon dites moi
une émission que vous aimez danser vous
détestez dans la nouvelle télévision
lors d'une émission que quitter trappe
qui est bien c'est les gens disent
on a supprimé les missions l'escargot
olemps démission de guy lux étaient
débiles et on l'a remplacé par les gens
d'ici c'était quand même un effort de
création bon merci attendait mathieu
bouchard vous êtes libraires oui
libraire asnières je voudrais dire
quelque chose qui m'a frappé déjà enfin
avant de venir dans les journaux
notamment un titre de six colonnes de
france soir après un sondage de dd il ya
peu de temps
six colonnes pour un sondage sur la
télévision après six mois de nouvelles
télévisions parce qu'il faut quand même
dire ça aussi cette télévision elle a
été changée 1 a progressé de temps mais
les nouveaux programmes ont commencé je
crois début janvier or deux mois après
les nouveaux programmes
on tire immédiatement sur la télévision
bon ben j'ai peur qu effectivement il ya
une exploitation un petit peu suspect
alors écoutez je ne peux g et comité
monsieur bouchard vous vraiment je peux
pas résister je vous avais dit que je
donnerais quand même quelques lectures
permettez moi maintenant alors de vous
donner une petite lecture de la presse
de ces dix dernières années ce sera très
rapide mais je voudrais vous dire que
chaque fois qu'il ya une émission
nouvelle à la télévision
voici comment elle est accueillie je
vais vous citer pour commencer
l'émission très anodines aujourd'hui
madame darmangeat mot pas une émission
méchante bon pour ou contre dans télé 7
jours le 35 70 c'est la nouvelle guerre
des deux roses aujourd'hui madame
attendue avec intérêt par toutes les
téléspectatrices déclenché depuis une
semaine une véritable bataille de dames
un des extraits de lettres de lecteurs
alléchés par l'annoncé d'une émission
destinée aux femmes je ne suis installé
fin de la lettre résultats dès le
lendemain je suis revenue à la radio et
mini grégoire autre lettre je vous
tenait pour un journaliste intelligent
vous venez monsieur jamot de mme
apporter la preuve du contraire en me
servant un plat réchauffé sans saveur et
en reprenant - femme pour une débile
mental voyez supportant une émission de
la zone neutre non non ce sont les
articles de la presse actuellement les
fronts attendez je continue monsieur
vous même comparé la vérité non mais
laissez moi terminer vous comparent
permettez je suis formel la qualité des
programmes je voudrais bien mais
quelqu'un disait c'est le fait monsieur
baumel la politisation la norme
permettez monsieur d'un combat en 1970
guy lux
bon qu'est ce qu'on disait de guy lux
hilux à innover son jeu la vie à deux
ans nous avons eu le premier numéro
samedi a dépassé de mousser précédents
jeux dans l'avilissement le grand
échiquier de jacques chancel une
émission qui respecté par tout le monde
aujourd'hui premier numéro titre dans
combat l'a fait manquer pour essayer
d'être drôle on pourrait commencer cette
critique par le grand échiquier bon dans
le monde on termine par l'intérêt tout
cela m'échappe parce que je n'aimerais
pas les variétés nathan le sage ou
encore bien il faut continuer les tests
continuent chez pour la non je te
comprends bien mais je vais tout ça veut
dire que les gens pas non plus
laissez-moi vous permettez je viens à la
conclusion plus qu'heureux que les
français vous écoute bernard pivot quand
il débute son émission claude sarraute
termine son article en disant un
magazine ne se juge pas à son premier
numéro attendant la suite
dans l'humanité la même chose dès son
année en arts pivot le temps de se roder
dans le figaro on ne juge pas la
première émission d'un magazine sur les
résultats mais sur les intentions il
faut attendre
je n'ai pu que ça dans aucun articles de
journaux sur une belle émission de cyril
du problème c'est les intentions
aujourd'hui qu'ils ne les at le résultat
ne correspond pas aux intentions alors
on se jette à la tête
la télévision dite de droite d'avant le
10 mai et la télévision dite de gauche
après le problème c'est qu'on attendait
un peu autre chose
on attendait des choses très différentes
et ici finalement les gens se battent en
disant si comme avant le mouvement
continue s'est politisée ce qui est vrai
c'est parfaitement vrai on parle du
téléspectateur on parle des produits on
parle pas de l'atmosphère qui règne dans
les rédactions et je crains pas d'être
démentie l'atmosphère dans les
rédactions est absolument détestable
sur les trois chaînes mon rôle ici un
peu aussi pour les journalistes ayant
pas qu'on les laisse travailler
monsieur baumel je vous assure qu'on
peut faire travailler dans une émission
un gaulliste et même un commune on peut
y arriver là si les hommes politiques
voulaient bien laisser des journalistes
un peu tranquille un moratoire disons
deux trois quatre cinq six mois ne
serait pas mal qui ne veut pas dire
qu'effectivement aujourd'hui mon cher
claude il y a quand même une
politisation et que les nominations ont
l'air jeudi ont l'air de se faire à la
sensibilité socialiste je ne donne pas
de noms mais on fait les nominations
avance mais c'est pas pour ça
pas dans le maire parlant sur la liste
noire dans les eaux néo le murcian n'ont
jamais écouté agressions etc où
j'arrivais dans la différence c'est que
les gens sous giscard n'avait pas de
carte du parti social du parti
giscardien mais ils étaient moins
nombreux aujourd'hui
non ce n'est pas sale et responsable il
ya pas mal de gens non qui pourrait
avoir écouté le cas tu parlais et petits
sets serrés détestable c'était une
pendant ces réseaux n'est plus la
chronique de télévision du figaro
magazine sous giscard je n'ai jamais mis
les pieds dans une émission de
télévision
je peux donc vous dire qu à cette époque
là jean françois kahn était à la
télévision et je l'écouté avec plaisir
il n'y avait donc pas ainsi que vous
laisser penser un tel ostracisme pour
les gens de gauche et intel favoritisme
pour les gens de droite je voudrais bien
simplement que je connais bien
simplement comment logis est hors diène
soyons pas naïfs comme les parent 1 1 un
dernier mot bombardier bombardier
écouter ceux qui arrivent et c'est ça le
problème c'est que c'est que et moi
étant d'aix de l'extérieur je peux dire
des choses même quand mes confrères
disent ils ne peuvent pas dire ce que
vous savez quand on est journaliste de
la télévision et qu'on veut faire la
télévision dans ce pays si on parle trop
et bien ça ça nous créer des problèmes
et on ne peut pas aller travailler dans
une télévision puisque a pas de
télévision privée bon ce qui est
frappant c'est que on attendait autre
chose n'est-ce pas de la télévision
socialiste ne serait ce que parce que
les socialistes ont dit qu'ils avaient
la vertu de leur côté plus fait pression
sur les buts en 157 non mais vous
connaissez constante compte dorénavant
sociaux de la vertu de leur côté ce qui
est frappant c'est que les interventions
gouvernementales depuis que depuis que
vous êtes au pouvoir ont été ont été
constantes il ya eu des déclarations de
m
journaliste à la télévision reçoivent
des téléphones les ministres a confié
qu'il avait étudié la télévision depuis
un an 75 mais vous savez on veut dire
combien de coups de téléphone on
recevait sous le précédent gouvernement
ces puzzles au rédacteur en chef jason
chen et canadiennes à coup sûr ne sait
qui sont les minutes suivant chez nous
il y en a pas beaucoup de lait serait
quand maman de cresson convoque un
rédacteur en chef directeur je ne sais
plus bien conduire mais enfin elle à
pontarlier quand dans la façade à façade
du mexique fait des pressions pour que
le reportage ne passe pas et que le pdg
vient au nombre pour dire que le
reportage est effectivement subjectif et
que ce n'est pas l'image du mexique
modernes comme le passé alors que sous
le gouvernement jusque là ils ne paient
pas seulement mais est-ce que ça c'est
pire parce que ce qu'elle pdg a faim
c'est qu'il a tiré sur tous ces
journalistes il a discrédité tous les
journalistes qui sont à sa chaîne et
c'est terrible ce concept une chose
inacceptable de faire ça n'en vaut pas
politique il ya une sanction soit
qu'elle voudrait donner à fond
direct par une commission de discipline
soit 110 le conseil d'administration
socialistes que de temps en temps elle
parce que les giscardiens n'avait pas
fait et qu'elle dise
en effet sur la télévision nous avons
fait des gaffes et moi j'aimerais que
certains spécialistes
oui j'oubliais ce qui les en priver mais
j'assure la direction la télévision
lorsqu'il ya un changement de voile à
l'écouté il vise aussi un dernier mot
revient bien vite qu'il appelle olivier
depuis 20 ans commence pas me donner
dieu sud unasur ont bien vite je dirai
ce que je ne cesse de semaine
additionnelle que le gouvernement a
commis une très grande erreur qui est de
ne pas avoir procédé à la réforme de
l'audiovisuel
immédiatement après sa prison j'ai fait
une erreur au congrès des choses qui est
pas très racée confond l'information les
programmes a voulu la snvi le rejet
d'iodé phénomène de recherche dans ce
domaine elle parle qui l'utilisent qui
est normal quand on est dans
l'opposition
c'est normal les autres l'aurait fait
aussi et c'est sur les programmes alors
je comptais une erreur qui a été commise
c'est que quand les gens votée le 10 mai
joe votez en fonction des problèmes
sociaux l'inflation jusqu'à etc n'ont
pas voté sur les programmes de
télévision et donner l'impression aux
gens que dans ce pays déjà bizarre où on
n'accepte pas l'alternance où il suffit
des sociaux démocrates arrivent au
pouvoir pour qu'on dise que s'arrête le
collectivisme et l'anarchie veillez donc
est allé à linverse quand ça sera les
autres qui viendront disant tension
c'est-à-dire ce livre c'est les
fascistes à dire on ne s'habitue pas à
l'alternance normal et bien donner
l'impression aux gens qu'on ne peut pas
avoir un changement de pouvoir et de
majorité sans changer la télévision
jusque dans les variétés jusque dans le
théâtre jusqu'en de cinéma c'est absurde
et c'est formidablement mal sa mauvaise
original et l'impression genre là que
parce qu'ils avaient voté pour mitterand
plutôt court giscard il fallait changer
les variétés il fallait changer au
théâtre ce soir il fallait que ça c'est
absurde
cela dit cela dit cela et en parlons de
choses concrètes
il se trouve moi je veux bien paraître
monsieur baumel il se trouve excusez moi
que j'allais programme de semaine
dernière c'est intéressant j'ai rien
mais moi j'aimerais qu'on voit je
commence dimanche
on peut en parler par d'autres choses
concrètes dimanche alors je vois que sur
la une
borsalino moi je suis très content
borsalino je suis très content qu'on ait
pu montrer aux français un éloge du
gangstérisme
un éloge du trafic de drogue qu'on ait
pu montrer aux français des surendettés
jour absolument merveilleux des
gangsters dans ce qu'il ya de pire qui
ensuite on finir la gestapo étaient
choqués barça est ce que là dessus
est-ce que ça ça m'a choqué ce qu'il n'a
pas existé je ne chanterai pas ce que je
suis à marseille c'est comme ça on
serait lourd mais c'est bien que vous me
dites très rapidement je suis désolé
c'est intéressant
j'ai les programmes parlons-en alors il
y avait borsalino sur la une
il y avait autre curiosité
de monsieur maurice rheims affecté drap
sur l'a2 et des variétés avec francis
cabrel duteil sur l'a3 est ce que
monsieur baumel c'est un mauvais
programme pourquoi qu'est ce qui était
mauvais qu'est ce qu'il faisait ennuyer
les gens
lundi il y avait sur la une un film avec
robert redford et charles bronson sur
l'a2 la callas intéressant et sur un
autre film sur l'a3 d'espionnage qu'est
ce que t'es mauvais monsieur eux de nous
quitter mardi la malle des indes
moi je n'ai pas vu mais il paraît que
c'est tout à fait excellent la main
désagréable c'est très marrant c'est
très publique
et croyez moi moi j'adore ce qui est
vraiment simple 1 à la télévision 2 le
téléfilm un téléfilm à l'échographie non
mais en soi c'est très concret c'est
quand même alors je dis la malle des
indes sur la une un téléfilm c'est
passage sur la deux c'est quand c'est
pas ça attendez je voudrais que les
trois attendait sur l'a3 la terre des
pharaons et après la terre des pharaons
le jour où la terre s'arrêta lire deux
filles ultra public et on peut continuer
là moi je dis à mes yeux mon rêve et on
peut compter 15 encaissés
concrètement qu'est ce qu'ils attaquent
la donne qu'est-ce qu'ils condamnent
qu'est ce qui était mauvais qu'est-ce
qu'il fallait pas faire à l'ancienne on
va voir échanger contre elle voulait
rénale
non mais je voudrais que j'aimerais
profiter que je voulais bien meilleure
des réponses alors un mot monsieur
baumel mais c'est sûr je m'excuse mais
il n'est pas sûr une semaine que des
millions de français ont fait leur
jugement sur une télévision ennuyeuse
triste et monotone
c'est parce qu'effectivement à tous il
ya un changement profond et je mets ce
que je vous le dira si cette semaine il
y à quelques films que vous signalez
malheureusement c'était bien ça mais ça
vous plaît grandement ce poème qui se
trouvait samia blement de très mauvais
goût de très mauvaise qualité vous me
les ont remplacés à ce que vous disent y
ait des choses précises oui cette
mission là bas
préférez un mot et des proches qui
attend la parole ça je remercie je
voudrais dire à cas précis c'est le cas
de l'information un journal été
complètement rénové on nous a dit que
soit retracerait à journal ouvert les
cinq premiers soirs de soir 3 il y à une
vedette chaque soir le premier soir
c'était le premier ministre
le deuxième soir c'était le président de
l'assemblée le troisième soir c'était
simone veil le quatrième soir s'était
mis les agricultures et le 5e ce soir
nobel pis c'est à dire quatre personnes
de gauche sur cinq est ce que c'est
représentatif de la france
est ce que c'est une ouverture voilà cas
précis sur lequel j'aimerais me fais
astier vous répondu ce sont les virages
qu'on ne juge pas sur cinq jours mais
jugé sur un mort sur scène
et bien sûr il a su être de gauche à
droite et les visions c'est me disait
pascal ministre à la télévision de
gauche à droite on en a pour des plans
d'études et d'ailleurs même les
évolutions les ailleurs
on en a marre de corrèze de doctrine
bon je vous donne un exemple quelque
chose qui n'a pas changé monsieur
mitterrand va aller en israël où quand
il va aller au japon
on va avoir le droit la semaine d'avant
un grand reportage sur le japon parce
que le prenons la république il va je
trouve ça scandaleux
si on doit parler aux gens qu'on a parle
un jour pas ce qui s'y passe quelque
chose et pas parce que le président de
la république y va et c'est la même
chose sous giscard et aujourd'hui c'est
que depuis la semoy mitterrand il
passait deux fois les accès mars à
maintenir des projets petit une petite
avance mais je voudrais mon droit de
réponse à jean françois quatre gardes et
noir qui nous asservit les programmes de
la semaine dernière moi j'ai ici telle
est cette poche montée ont très mal son
ouverture à la acquis mais là bas voilà
elle s'est laissée bruitages journal de
télévision les programmes de la semaine
prochaine sont beaucoup plus
encourageants que ceux de la semaine
dernière
d'abord demain matin à 9h30 et
orthodoxie qui est une émission
formidable où on voit pas monsieur
ferrer ni monsieur baumel les messieurs
car c'est là c'est la seule n'y a même
pas travolta dimanche après midi à une
émission fantastique qui s'appelle
incroyable mais vrai où le présentateur
va montrer un cheveu de 5 cm ah oui
c'est mais c'est incroyable mais vrai je
le sais mais c'est très bien ensuite
lundi matin lundi matin une très bonne
émission qui sur tf1 qui s'appelle les
visiteurs du jour d'anne sinclair
alors c'est le thème du saumon et sur
l'alternance anne sinclair reçoit daniel
gilbert sur tf1 l'a dit vous pouvez
compter sur nous c'est une nouvelle
émission de pierre bellemare alors là
une dame qui demandait un chien aveugle
depuis dix ans si c'est vraiment
intéressant mais alors en lui
téléphonait de la mairie pour lui
d'aller chercher à la vague mais comme
elle était sourde et moins d'espoir
finalement grâce à bellemare est un
berger allemand qui n'arrête pas de la
mort parce que les arabes mais en face
ça peut être une bonne émission
oui lundi le journal die welt en dari
20h le journal de 20h lundi le journal
de 20 heures lundi et exceptionnelle
ayant une interview de madame annie
grangier qui est présidente de
l'association des femmes battues qui
viendra que des photos d'anne sinclair
dernier
vous aurez également lundi toujours sur
fr3 qui est une très bonne chaîne
l'émission s'appelle décrochage régional
je pratique des vues et rennes nantes
présente une émission qui s'appelle et
cléo el diez où mène au de goudou goudou
pile au poët poët c'est une bonne
émission aussi toute la semaine bien sûr
que c'est game épreuves sportives mardi
mardi sur antenne 2 des chiffres et des
lettres
la faune le patrice laffont va parler de
ses lectures préférées qui sont consonne
voyelle voyelles voyenne personnes
les gens d'ici vous ne parliez tout à
l'heure des gens d'ici c'est une
émission formidable de gens qui n'ont
rien à dire qu'ils disent avec beaucoup
d'émotion qu'il le dise longtemps et ils
le disent très longtemps oui en costumes
mercredi lac redire le magazine de
l'onisep que personne ne regarde une
heure assez bâtards que dès 13h40 le
magazine onisep un métier pour demain
aujourd'hui rien au passé le thème les
jeux de 20 heures les jeux de 20 heures
le mot clé est fracturé avec un sinclair
je vais arriver au bout de la semaine
comme ça je dis réponse à tout la
question est quand je pense à fernande
que dois-je faire
jeudi encore sur antenne 2 histoires d'à
bonheur à cette infecte enquête - qui
nous tire les larmes qui existe depuis
un moment
29e épisode alice veut cacher une jeune
juive chez elle mais en deçà appartient
à la gestapo sent-il voilà au sort ça
c'est le feuilleton qui bouge
jeudi encore télévision régionale peu
trop peut-on apprivoiser une huître par
le professeur fournier c'est une
émission qui fait bâiller oui
certainement alors apostrophe surtout à
passer le ratez pas pas soit parce qu on
a déjà parlé des grandes lignes il y
aura philippe labro qui veut parler de
son livre
marcel jullian et surtout jean pierre
elkabbach jean pierre elkabbach pourrait
me coûter c'est normal qu'ils parlent un
peu de son livre qui s'appelle crise et
vous labro que vendredi
vendredi les jeux de 20 heures avec
nicole questiaux qui jouera le mot et
beyrouth
et puis samedi enfin pour finir droit de
réponse oui on termine droit de réponse
de michel polac et qui s'obstine
alors le tenait michelle plat qui
s'obstine à refuser de nous dire dès le
lundi la liste des invités qui dresse le
jeudi et le thème de l'émission sera
dois t'en dresser la liste des invités
des lacs
alors je dernier monstre grassi décroche
un mot j'aimerais avoir l'avis de
monsieur je l'espère qui est de bien du
luxembourg aujourd'hui pour nous parler
il a un intérêt particulier monsieur
chester ils peuvent capter théoriquement
strassen est en tout cas une entrée
seulement alors sur huit chaînes
l'allemande la belge la française et
luxembourgeoise
est-ce que la française vous paraît
catastrophique monsieur je l'espère
depuis quelques temps non certains n'ont
pas je crois c'est que nous une chance
qu'une partie de l'éventail des
programmes que nous pouvons en voir et
la bougeotte
il ya des gens chez nous à qui ça ne
plaît pas tellement et bien ils ont la
possibilité qu'on ne sont pas enchaîner
à la télévision française
ils peuvent changer car toute façon un
peu plus de la moitié des gens regardent
plutôt le programme allemand je dirais
une majorité assez légère donc nous ne
sommes pas les mains liées
vers vos programmes je voulais ajouter
un mot moi j'ai pris au pied de la
lettre le titre de l'émission là la télé
en procès et sans entrer dans des
discussions de deux sondages ou de
qualité de non qualité
je voudrais faire en deux mois un procès
les gens regardent la télé beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup trop et je ne dis pas
en tant que spectateur subjectif je le
dis en tant qu'enseignants et je
m'étonne qu'on n'est pas avec un seul
mort ce soir parler des jeunes qui
regardent la télé jour par jour par jour
et je vous assure le lundi par exemple
lorsqu'on entre dans les classes eh bien
on est devant des jeunes gens totalement
et complètement déboussolé et déboussolé
ça prend un jour vous ne lèvera jusqu'à
ce que je pense et je crois qu'on peut
difficulté soyez prêt que c'est parce
que nous écartons mais notre émission de
ce soir la salle jean vincent placé au
centre du sujet la télé en procès il ne
suffira pas de discuter maintenant telle
émission best notre émission monde
il faut au moins aussi que je me mette
dans le débat ce truisme que les gens
regardent beaucoup trop et vous vous
occupez c'est bien vous préoccuper des
programmes d'aujourd'hui et de demain
moi je me préoccupe journellement
téléspectateurs d'aujourd'hui et de
demain
et c'est pas une chose facile je vous
assure bon moi j'ai calculé daudet
astier le voudrait reprendre ce qu'a dit
madame bombardier qu'on a sur la cour on
n'a pas ça assez insisté c'est qu'il
s'agit d'un phénomène en europe
occidentale
aujourd'hui on regarde moins la
télévision et les gens peut-être ont
réappris à sortir de chez eux à faire
autre chose et ça explique aussi
pourquoi il ya une plus grande
fréquentation du cinéma c'est un
problème qui est très important c'est
quand même dès que j'ai mal j'ai chéri
maintiennent dans la confusion des
genres
hier c'est vrai que les gens regardent
un peu moins la télévision si vous
autorisez la possible en alsace mais les
gars et en galets ne vous autorise
sûrement pas a dit qu' il n'y a pas en
ce qui concerne non pas la télévision en
général et c'est rien c'est plein de
gens mais certaines innovations de la
télévision et certaines émissions
particulière un mécontentement très fort
dont il serait temps de tenir compte de
la même manière qu'il faut bien
constater comme l'a fait olivier todd
que l'on fait plusieurs intervenants
depuis tout à l'heure quand ce qui
concerne un problème qui n'est pas le
propre de toute la télévision parce que
encore une fois comme d'habitude chaque
fois qu'on parle de la télévision on
consacre les deux tiers du temps à
parler de l'information et les
programmes passent à peu près à la salle
au delà je voudrais dire qu'un
rapidement là dessus que les trois
quarts des programmes qu'on voit
actuellement ont été décidé par les
présidents précédents présidents
responsables aux échecs que par ailleurs
et la bonté de me laisser terminer que
par ailleurs il y a eu en ce qui
concerne les responsables des programmes
extrêmement peu pour ne pas dire pas du
tout de changement
combien de gens à un niveau de
responsabilité décisionnelle sont entrés
par exemple la tf quatre en comptant le
président le président le directeur
hervé caux de l'isaf et six mois
terminées
laissez-moi terminée
il y a eu extrêmement peu de changements
ces cancers des gens que les cinémas il
faut donc dire que les gens qui signent
les contrats et qui ont vocation à le
faire sont dans bien des cas les mêmes
et que nous prépare le même genre
d'émission de fiction si elles ne
plaisent pas maintenant elle ne plaisait
pas non plus comme vous en souvenez
avant est en tout cas d'un état
responsabilité mais simplement ce qui
concerne l'autre partie qui la partie
politique il faut quand même c'est quand
même assez frappant de voir que chaque
fois qu'on a reproché une forme
d'interventionnisme à l'actuel
gouvernement à l'égard des programmes
d'information des journaux les gens du
gouvernement où les gens du parti
socialiste comme claude estier l'a fait
ce soir répondre mais avant c'est
vraiment la même chose
alors si le changement c'est de prendre
rencontre d'autres gens des silhouettes
aminé vous serez gentil si le changement
c'est de prendre d'autres gens pour
faire la même chose
en effet ça ne valait pas vraiment la
peine et comme on chantait autrefois
c'était pas la peine assurément de
changer de gouvernement
alors toute la question en effet elle
est de savoir maintenant si oui ou non
on va avoir d'une part une nouvelle loi
de l'audiovisuel qui organise son
indépendance mans là dessus je veux dire
qu'il faut être relativement pessimiste
parce que le gouvernement cet été a
nommé une commission qui s'appelle la
commission moineau pour faire un rapport
en ce qu'ils devaient présenter la
télévision du futur
cette commission elle a jugé que c'était
un digne d'elle de faire un constat de
faire l'inventaire des lieux et de dire
voilà la télévision actuellement est
organisé comme ça si on veut des
programmes plus varié plus vivant plus
plaisant pour les téléspectateurs
il faudrait changer tel et tel système
de production télé tel système de
contrats tels et tels systèmes de
rémunération tel et tel système de
fonctionnement ça la commission moineau
a considéré que c'était pas bon pour
elle n'importe quel président qui prend
une nouvelle entreprise dans le privé
commence par faire faire ce qu'on
appelle un audit c'est à dire un état
des lieux qui ont dit voilà comment ça
se passe à la télévision n'a pas fait
par contre on a rêvé à des structures
pour le futur dont on ne sait absolument
pas ce qu'elles vont donner vu qu'elles
n'ont pas de fondations l'onu notamment
le juré apte à des hans
yatim tchèque qui a tort laquelle le
canada beaucoup parlé yann irlandais
parmi nous intiment aux jets
les votre impression trouve au débat
très stérile parce que je trouve que le
moment historique est venu pour que la
france entre dans le xxème siècle en
termes de télévision je pense que si
vous aviez dit chen oui quand le xv au
disque on vient à bruxelles
vous n'aurez pas ce débat et tous les
autres des responsables de télévision
dans les grandes pays s'accordent à dire
aujourd'hui qu'on ne peut plus servir le
public comme le grand public avec un
menu ce n'est plus possible il faut
servir les publics et les moyens
techniques sont là les autres pays du
monde les grands pays où on fabrique la
télévision il y à un évolution
d'activité les gens en train de faire de
fabriquer de se mettre ensemble pour
faire des sociétés de créer dans tous
les sens en france on rentre en france
et tout est bloqué personne ne peut rien
faire du tout et qu'il est quoi le
regarde que trois chaînes de télévision
et michel avait dit il ya le filet puis
à deux on est d'accord et j'entendais
qu'on parle d'une chaîne privée
tous les stéréotypes qui remonte
puissances d'argent
il comprend mais restent élevés
on va pas refaire le débat sur les
radios libres mais enfin quand même
comme ça hallucinant que à la fin du 20e
siècle on en soit encore vous dire que
c'est l'argent qui pervertit la
télévision authority français peuvent
très facilement augmenter le nombre de
services en fait de l'impétrant
s'emportant kitty ce que vous appelez un
monopole de diffusion car il n'y a plus
de monopole de programmation
c'est vraiment bien aussi j'ai des
radios libres à monsieur meyer ce que je
voudrais confrères nous responsables
européens eu la parole devrait juste un
petit mot dhainaut de téléspectateurs
bon monsieur dupuis laquelle quelle est
votre impression sur cette nouvelle télé
vous vous êtes bien moins je regarde la
télévision pour me distraire g
on pourra trouver des trucs intéressants
et que disons qu'il ya des choses qui
ont disparu et je trouvais ça
souhaitable ya des choses qui sont
apparus que je ne mets pas toujours mais
dans l'ensemble j'arrive encore à
trouver mon bonheur devant la télé dans
ce qui est apparu qu est ce que vous
aimez dans les nouvelles émissions
j'aime l'émission de jean françois kahn
s'était pas préparé oui et dans
l'émission encore oui on a il y en a
quand même
enfin vous êtes marie rose est il un ou
des publicités et la praticité pas
catastrophé en plus qu à part ces deux
nouvelles télés n'ont pas encore et
votre voisin est un jeune chômeur vous
êtes étudiant lui ben moi je crois que
le changement c'était le samedi on avait
numéro 1 maintenant c'est le mardi on la
formule 1 plus 1 voilà c'est ça le
changement puisse le changement c'était
la politique
alors avant sa politique de droite
maintenant sa politique de gauche je
crois que ce qui a été intéressant les
gens qu'on dit des choses intéressantes
aujourd'hui c'était pas tellement des
politiciens parce que j'ai souvent vu
anne aymone s'endormir quand il parlait
presque à elle riait quand c'était plus
drôle concertée de l'autre côté de la
table reste est plus drôle puis elle
rien parce que d'autres camps par les
politiques à son dormait puis moi aussi
d'ailleurs vous êtes des projets un vous
voyez un peu oui à bien des fous anémone
c'est vrai ça vous aviez envie de vous
endormir la politique ça vous intéresse
pas et la télé qu'est ce que vous en
pensez alors anémone il faut rappeler
tout de même qu'à damon en ce moment est
l'héroïne d'un film comique et on a bien
besoin de rire en ce moment puisque tout
le monde le dit un film qui s'appelle ma
femme s'appelle reviens et c'est vous la
femme celle qui vient d
oui qu'on n'attend pas et qu'est ce que
vous en pensez de la télé vous comme
comédienne moi je regarde pas tellement
la télé parce que j'ai la chance de bien
aimer parler à mon jules à l'heure du
dîner
et puis après il n'y a plus rien et puis
alors donc je vais au cinéma voilà je
préfère le cinéma parce qu'au cinéma ya
700 trine par an alors c'est vrai qu'on
peut qu'on a beaucoup plus de choix et
que tu y en a pour tous les goûts
c'est vrai qu'avec une chose anémone
c'est qu'il n'y avait pas une politique
très sérieuse pour les jeunes comédiens
jusqu'à ce que vous soyez une vedette on
vous proposait rien oui mais ça je crois
que c'est pas c'est pas nouveau ce truc
là c'est parce que à l'époque où je
faisais ce qu'on appelle le couloir de
la honte qui est au foot et du temps le
rtf que j'étais ce titre oui c'est vous
savez c'est le couloir où il ya tous les
bureaux de metteur en scène le comédien
oui et où tous les comédiens portent
comme salon gamme audio non elle la
trouve que là et on ne va pas et je veux
dire c'est vrai qu'il revient pas là
dans une ambiance révolutionnaire ni
rigolote ni décoincer ni bon mais
apparemment ça a pas spécialement
changée puisque c'est du jour où j'ai
commencé à faire des on a commencé à me
proposer des grands rôles au cinéma que
les jeunes télévision soumis à m'appeler
alors que jusque là je crois que je
reviens horreur et pour me proposer des
petites pannes oui c'est à dire que vous
avez un peu l'impression qu'il y avait
un super enfin j'exagère parce qu'il ya
aussi des gens mais il ya des gens bien
partout je n'y voyais avait un petit
conservatisme dans la politique des
dramatiques c'est ça vous voulez dire on
ne faisait pas tellement appel aux
jeunes comédiens on peut pas dire que
les comédiens du splendid ont une grande
aide de la télévision ces dernières
années pour démarrer c'est ça ne voulait
venir annoncer après qu'ils ont démarré
que la télévision c'est sur ce sommet
contradiction non mais ça c'est un petit
ça donne l'impression d'un je connais
rien monsieur le président voilà qu'est
ce qu'on va dire un mot des critiques de
télévision un mot ce thème était
bénéfique cellulaire dans les nouvelles
littéraires il ya quelqu'un qui a écrit
que c'était des clowns moi je dirais
carrément des guignols ont écrit
n'importe quoi n'importe écouter avec se
contredisant tout le temps si vos
enfants ce droit car personnellement il
m'a dit que j'étais un démagogue jeu
c'est vrai jeu j'aime le théâtre de
boulevard
j'aime les films avec jean gabin j'aime
les films policiers j'aime les variétés
avec mary mathieu c'est mon goût c'est
comme ça j'aime ça donc vous ne
trouverez jamais sous ma plume une ligne
où j'ai dit il faut une des visions plus
culturelle plus didactique je lis jamais
dit mais d'autres l'ont dit et je les ai
lus ils l'ont dit ils ont critiqué et
variétés à plumes
ils ont critiqué m théâtre de boulevard
ils ont brigué beaucoup de critiques de
gauche park des critiques de gauche et
abrite atteignant sous leur influence
on a commencé à faire une télévision un
peu différente un peu plus culturelle
comme vous diriez et un petit culturel
quand vous direz on les a vus se
retourner complètement et détruire ce
qu'ils avaient adoré dire le contraire
et massacré avec vraiment
l'irresponsabilité de celui qui est dans
son fauteuil et qui d'ailleurs pour
certains ne sont pas venus ici je suis
surpris je croyais voir ici c'est
tellement facile et derrière son
fauteuil ou sans dire où sont-ils g20
pas bon et bien ces gens là ils ont
changé la seule qu avec une démagogie
incroya ils disaient nous voulons la
culture nous voulons des concerts ne
voulant plus peur à nous voulons des
grandes pièces on leur fout de giraudoux
voilà pourquoi c'est ennuyeux et c est
un dernier exemple douglas il a fait ya
trois semaines un monsieur souvent je
crois qu'on est d'accord sur tout il a
fait une il a fait une émission pierre
douglas fantastique où il y avait près
d'accord ou vraiment c'était en même
temps culturel et on s'ennuyer par y ont
passé une soirée formidable vous l'avez
vu pas une critique le lendemain
monsieur pas une critique dans la presse
la vétéran françois il ya il ya ces
démissions que le problème de la
télévision dans ce pays c'est le
problème des crédits non non non non
mais il ya un problème et il ya eu
d'énormes occasions il y avait il ya eu
énormément de nouvelles émissions et
j'ai demandé à tous les conducteurs
il n'y a pas eu de transfert des
nouvelles émissions de détails
je voudrais vous dire que justement ce
n'est pas très connu c'est que lorsqu'on
320 ch face au public en 1971 le public
se plaignaient les miss émissions
culturelles sont trop tard un bon matin
là on se plaint de centres auto
bon les téléspectateurs disais pourquoi
avait-on supprimer les cinq dernières
minutes en votre âme et conscience sa
caméra explore le temps tu as des
preuves c'est très bien des années à
chaque fois les prix ont des émissions
j'ai joué tellement elle et lui
donc si on en suivant mais jamais on
n'en fera jamais nouvelle parce que les
chaînes n'ont pas réglé le problème
foot problèmes de concurrence non là je
n'ai pas le petit nicolas pineault
arrêté et je me demande si par exemple
signer directeurs de chaînes s'entendent
m qui peut entrer faisais ce que font
les gens en angleterre la bobby's soit
deux coups de faux mais c'est une
vieille dame qui a fait ses preuves il
est admis en angleterre que la chaîne
numéro un se livrent un public un peu
plus vaste elle fait les délices de
jean-françois par exemple et que la
chaîne numéro deux est un tout petit peu
plus culturel un tout petit peu plus
sophistiqué et le choix libre et laissé
dans la mécanique actuelle ça c'est
complètement bloquée
je suis obligé de dire si vous permettez
je crois que le vrai problème est là et
bien un mot il ya un mot qu'on n'a pas
prononcé dans cette émission qui est le
mot harmonisation et en parler mais je
ne peux pas parler mini le dernier mot
jean ferré mon amour le changement sera
relayée sur le web nous venons de parler
des programmes
nous venons changé c'est compliqué
aujourd'hui est ce que les ministres
téléphone y en a changé de ministre est
ce à cause des programmes non avec un
nouveau genre et verrait bien c'était je
voudrais dire simplement ceci les
programmes les programmes il faut des
mois éventuellement des années pour les
changer parce que le temps de faire une
dramatique c'est long bien au chaud
on peut changer tout de suite c'est
l'information ce sont les journaux il
serait peut-être intéressant d'andy rihs
de mots pour avoir une influence sur
monsieur verrez ce soir c'était dit
beaucoup alors écoutez monsieur
l'aspirante encore je ne renonce pas
là-dessus l'émission de la télévision
je vais faire si tous je vous donne
rendez vous samedi prochain pour une
émission consacrée au jeu aux joueurs au
tiercé au casino si vous voulez
témoigner dans l'émission écrivez-nous
rapidement nous vous inviterons merci
bonsoir à tous
[Musique]